[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ELISABETH BARGES: Thank
you very much to be here.
Very happy to have this
discussion with you tonight.
So maybe a few words
about each of you, maybe
starting with Ludwine, because
I have your name on my paper.
No, nice to see you Ludwine.
We already know each other.
A few words about you--
so actually, you're
a data engineer at
Leboncoin, right?
LUDWINE PROBST:
Yes, from tomorrow.
I start tomorrow on my new job.
ELISABETH BARGES:
OK, congratulations.
LUDWINE PROBST: Thank you.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yes, congrats.
OK, and Sophie
Bled, can you-- so
you're co-founder of Gloomywood.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED:
Yes, you said it.
ELISABETH BARGES: OK.
Nothing else to add
about what you did?
SOPHIE ANNE BLED:
So [INAUDIBLE].
ELISABETH BARGES: Please
use your microphone.
It's working.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: Hello?
ELISABETH BARGES: Yes.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: So Gloomywood
is a very young studio,
created one year ago.
And we are focusing on
our first video game.
It's "2Dark," and we hope
it will be a success.
And it's very exciting.
We are supposed to be at
the end of production,
but everything is not finished.
But it will be amazing.
ELISABETH BARGES: OK, great.
And what about Emily?
You're running Women
Who Code, right?
EMILY REESE: Yeah.
I run Women Who Code, which
is an organization here
in Paris for women who
already work in technology.
And that's only in the evenings,
though, when we have meetups.
And then during the day, I
teach French and English code
courses, how to build
websites and design websites.
And I've been living in Paris
for about a year and a half.
But as you can hear,
I'm from the US.
ELISABETH BARGES: OK,
thank you very much.
Melanie, you are co-founder
of Atelier [SPEAKING FRENCH].
I will say it in French maybe.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: 801,
if you want, in English.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yeah.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: We are a
small indy game studio company,
and we found the company over
the success of our first video
game, that is Transformice.
It's a massively
multiplayer browser game.
And now we have 10 employees,
and we just run the company
and make more games.
ELISABETH BARGES:
Very impressive.
Congratulations.
So maybe to start
the discussion,
I will start with something
inspired from the talk we just
listened from Camille.
Can I ask you,
maybe to you, Emily,
the moment when
you were thinking
that you found your way?
EMILY REESE: Yeah, I
guess the most recent time
that I've been
thinking I'm lost and I
need to find where I am and
arrive at a place was when
I was trying to move to France.
I think--
ELISABETH BARGES: Of course.
EMILY REESE: I came here-- huh?
EMILY REESE: Yeah, it's
actually very hard,
which I think as Americans we
don't recognize all the time,
to move to a different country.
So I had no visa or
rights to come here.
I had to find a job
and be sponsored.
And I think as women,
there are a lot less women
that travel abroad
internationally and live
internationally than men.
And I think as I've
been researching online
for other women going
through the same thing,
adjusting to life
in a new country,
it seems to be there are a
lot of women that follow men,
like the man has a job, so
he goes to a new country,
and the wife goes
along with them.
And so navigating that, and
then also be in technology, when
you're looking for a job,
and like Camille was saying,
you feel like you're
not good enough.
And you're also looking for
a job in a foreign country.
It's a lot of factors
at the same time,
and you feel like you're
not worthy of being there.
But I would say this
has been the greatest
personal inner success
that I've ever experienced.
And it's just a
visa in my passport.
It's nothing special.
But getting a job
in another country
and living in a
different culture
and adjusting to
those rules was worth
the months-long struggle
and perseverance
of being able to build
technology in a new place.
ELISABETH BARGES: Sure.
I perfectly understand
the difference
between countries [INAUDIBLE].
Maybe we also heard a little
bit from the talk of Camille
that it can be-- she talked
about the imposter syndrome,
that we also have the default,
maybe sometimes, or some women,
not to be proud of our
success, to share them,
and to brand a
little bit ourselves.
So maybe a question
to you, Sophie Anne.
What is your position about
it regarding yourself?
How do you advocate
for yourself?
SOPHIE ANNE BLED:
Well, I have to say
I'm not good at this game.
But I know I have to improve it.
And the point is, sometimes you
just have to force yourself,
because if you don't
advocate for yourself,
the only person will
do it is your mother.
And it's not enough.
ELISABETH BARGES: Good point.
Fair point.
Do you have concrete actions
you are trying to do right now?
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: Yes, I'm here.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yeah, OK.
Fair point.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: So I
stay there in the office,
either in my desk.
ELISABETH BARGES:
Very fair point.
Maybe I would like to also
have another point of view,
[INAUDIBLE] Emily?
Oh, sorry, Melanie, excuse me.
Melanie, excuse me.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: I
knew that would come up.
[LAUGHTER]
ELISABETH BARGES: Melanie.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: What am
I doing to promote myself?
ELISABETH BARGES:
Yes, yes, please.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: Well,
I use Twitter a lot.
I'm not sure that counts.
I'm not sure this works.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yeah, it is.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: Yeah, it's
very difficult for a woman
to advocate for herself, because
it's often taken as bragging.
And self-assurance is
not well seen in women,
because people think that
they are braggy and stuff.
But we must do it.
This is really, really
important for us to do it,
because we need to
inspire the youngest,
to show-- we need really
to force ourselves,
like Sophie Anne said, to
advocate for women in tech
and to show the youngest
that it is possible
and that they shouldn't
stop themselves
from going into this field.
ELISABETH BARGES:
I agree with you,
and I also think that--
and I can apply this
to myself, that we probably
sometimes also need
to force ourselves to
connect with others,
because it's also part of
branding to meet people
and say, yes, I'm doing this,
blah, blah, blah, et cetera.
And so it's something where
I know that in each event
I come, I force myself to
speak at least three people,
I don't know.
So sometimes it's not a
very-- it doesn't follow up
or anything.
But it's a good
exercise, I think.
And maybe a question to Ludwine.
So you said to us that you're
going to take a new job very
soon-- tomorrow.
So maybe a word about,
in your situation,
and regarding your experience.
I know that you had a tough
moment in your career.
And I would like to
know how you kept your--
if you did-- your
kept your confidence
and trust in yourself?
LUDWINE PROBST: Yes.
So the past year, I was-- yeah,
it has been very hard for me.
I was in burnout mode, so
I quit everything-- my job,
the city, Brest.
And I came back to Paris.
I was also very involved
in an association,
but it was not really good.
So yes, I quit everything.
And then I was thinking
about, what can I do?
What can I do now, because
I don't have anything else?
And I worked so hard
to have all of this,
and now I have nothing.
And I thought about
when I was a child,
and I thought about my dreams.
And I had a dream, and one of
my dreams is pretty common.
It was about traveling
across the world.
So because I had nothing to
lose, I decided to leave Paris
and to travel in Asia.
So I'm just coming
back from Asia,
where I have been three months.
And because I wanted to add
something very personal,
I decided to meet tech
communities in here,
and especially I wanted
to meet women in tech.
I was curious about, OK, what is
being a developer in Malaysia,
in Nepal?
Do they have the
same technology?
Do they use the same technology?
What kind of challenge
do they have?
What kind of startups
do they create?
And how many women are
working in tech in the here?
So as you can imagine,
it was very exciting,
and it was awesome.
I met inspiring women and men.
And I don't know.
I called this project
Tech Beyond Borders,
because I wanted to learn
about other people in tech.
And--
ELISABETH BARGES: So maybe
the tip in that situation,
a difficult situation, was
to really go deep in yourself
and to find the
resource in yourself?
LUDWINE PROBST: I
think when someone,
you are in a bad situation,
when you have nothing to lose,
you can take risks.
And I did.
I was really sad,
and I decided just
to create something
positive with this travel
and to come back with--
ELISABETH BARGES:
With a lot of energy.
LUDWINE PROBST: I
just want to say,
if you are in a bad
situation in your life,
it's not so bad, because
you can create something.
Sometimes if you're
in a bad situation,
if you have nothing to lose,
maybe it is at this time
that you can make
a big decision.
For me, it was the case.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yes.
And I heard recently a very
successful entrepreneur,
a woman, and when she
explained her story,
she says that when she
heard a lot of, no, you
should not do that, you should
not create this company,
this is a bad idea, this
is, et cetera-- very
negative opinions, so she said,
OK, so many people told me
it's a bad idea.
Let's just try.
And I was-- yeah,
I mean, she was--
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: It
couldn't be worse.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yeah, exactly.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: It's
just it couldn't be worse.
ELISABETH BARGES:
People depressed me,
so I won't be more
depressed than I already am.
So maybe Emily, you seem
to have a lot of energy.
Did you-- not when you
came to France, maybe
another situation,
but maybe a moment
where you felt it was
a hard moment for you,
and you-- as Ludwine
said, what was your method
at this moment to try
to feel again your trust
and energy in yourself?
EMILY REESE: I think
of my past few years
as being like a series
of different struggles
and then coming out
on the other side.
So before coming here to
France, I-- back story,
I did not study, even in school,
didn't do any sort of master's
in computer science,
could not have told you
what HTML stood for-- nothing.
And I did my
masters in the arts.
I was an artist and studied
art history and architecture.
And my first job after
getting my masters
was at Kickstarter,
which at the time
was relatively known in the US,
but we didn't operate anywhere
outside the US.
And we had only had a handful
of really successful projects,
so it was mostly
small-scale artists
and musicians and filmmakers
using the platform.
So when you're working on
something really inspiring
like this, and you're
seeing that a website is
able to change people's
lives completely,
like they're able to live
their dreams or this project
that they've had
in mind for years,
they do it thanks
to just a website.
So I thought it was
really important to learn
what this tool was that was
enabling people to live out
the things that
they wanted to do,
that they wouldn't have been
able to do without just typing
their stuff on a keyboard and
making a Kickstarter project.
So I taught myself
how to code, which
in hindsight, to say the
sentence "I taught myself
how to code," is annoying,
because everyone says that once
they learn.
And it makes it
sound really easy,
like it wasn't a problem at all.
But when you're
coming from nothing,
you're starting totally
from zero, that's
imposter syndrome to the max.
I was 23 at the time, and I just
finished a masters in a field
that I was really
good at, and then went
from being really
good at something
to being completely
at amateur level--
amateur in the English sense,
not in the French sense, which
means beginner.
And yeah, so just
pushing through that,
and then having a
support system--
I know Camille was saying that
we have a tendency to attribute
our successes to luck,
which I would have said
was the case, because I
already worked at a startup.
I already had access
to a code base
and developers who
kind of showed me
how to do this type of thing.
And then I switched to
the engineering team
six months later.
So if I hadn't been
in that position,
I asked myself all
the time, would I
have been lucky enough
to end up where I am now?
But I think it's not luck.
It's just being in the right
place at the right time.
And if you're not in the
right place at the right time,
you actually kind of are.
You just find another key to
a different door that ends up
taking you to the same place.
So I would say, I don't know.
Finding your way
is-- you never even
know that you're
finding your way,
because you're always just doing
what you're doing every day.
But you're actually on
a path, and you just
have to look far ahead enough to
see where that path might lead,
and then just stick to it.
ELISABETH BARGES: Thank you.
Another topic where we may--
I don't know, I'm not sure,
but we may have
some-- I don't know,
some difficulties,
which is negotiating.
I think there are figures
about the way women are not
negotiating their salary.
But apart from the
pure salary question,
I would like to maybe ask
to you about that question.
How in your company--
because you have a company,
so you have employees,
and you have, of course,
negotiation discussions
about, I don't know.
So what is the way you
are dealing with that?
Is it something difficult
for you, or not at all,
or can you tell us about this?
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: For me,
it's one of the best parts
of the job, because I like to--
ELISABETH BARGES:
Oh, interesting.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: I
like to find-- for me,
a good deal is a
fair deal, so you
have to understand
what the other wants,
and where you are ready to go.
So it's not only with
negotiating salary.
It's also in a commercial
negotiation, so for everything.
The best way is,
first, to know what
you want, what you are willing
to go so far with concession,
what is your goal.
Also, listen to the other
party, what they want.
What is their motivation?
What is the key point?
And you have to listen to
people and try to understand
where they want to go.
And after you see what could
be the strategy, to have
the-- each party is happy.
This is the challenge, to
make each parties happy.
And sometimes you
have to take the time.
And I think that's-- when
you go to a breaking point
in negotiation, you
have to have, oh,
let's see that next week.
Let's take the time to
just keep the door open.
And after, you come
back a week later,
and sometimes you
have just reconsidered
things, reconsidered with
another angle, and it fits.
ELISABETH BARGES: So it's more
negotiations for your company
than for yourself, right?
I mean, do you think you
will have a different--
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: I
think it's the same.
I think that the basis
of the negotiation for me
is just to understand
the point for each party.
And this is horrible,
even in commercial,
trying to interpersonal
things, to have
to understand what is the deal
and what does really matter.
Why is this person in front
of you, in your office saying
this, this, this, this?
What does she feel?
What does she want, really?
And sometimes what she wants
is not what she's saying.
So you have to go further,
the first sentence,
and to take time.
ELISABETH BARGES:
And still regarding
the fact that you
are managing people,
what are your considerations
to hire someone?
Do you have an ideal,
or a candidate or team
you want to build within your
company regarding-- I mean,
your strengths and maybe
the things that you're
looking for within candidates
and future employees?
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: Well,
the first, of course,
is the skill and the competence.
But after-- my goal is to have
a happy team that fits together,
that can interact together.
They will be happy to go
and happy to be themselves
in the morning, to have coffee.
It's just because you are
working eight-- sorry, seven
hours a day.
ELISABETH BARGES: [INAUDIBLE].
SOPHIE ANNE BLED:
So the best way
to have good work is
to have a good team,
and a happy team which is
not-- oh, no, not this job.
I don't want to go.
But people who are happy
together and happy to exchange
and to build something
together, because we
are making video
games, but it's not
the video game of one person.
It's the video game,
in fact, of the team.
And this is what is
very important for me.
ELISABETH BARGES: So
together, everybody
around a project, and to
have a common vision of this,
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: Yes, yes.
ELISABETH BARGES:
Melanie, I don't
know if you want to add a word
about this, as a co-founder,
also, of your company?
MELANIE CHRISTIN: Yeah,
I manage also 10 people,
so I'm in kind of
the same situation.
I've had some management
problems earlier last year,
and it really took a
toll on the company.
And I really want to
talk about it so people
can avoid it in any way.
I'm really bad at
management, really.
ELISABETH BARGES: What does
that mean, you're really bad?
I mean, I know a
lot of bad managers,
and they are managing.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: Nobody
complains about you, Melanie.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: You're not
talking to the right persons.
I don't have a lot of empathy.
I find it really hard to
read other people's emotions.
This is something
really personal.
So I wanted to tackle out of the
that the stereotype about women
being more sensitive and
more caring and stuff.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: We agree.
MELANIE CHRISTIN:
This is not the case.
Really, this is not.
I don't always understand
what someone is telling me
when they are telling me
something, because of course--
and it's not always
what they are saying.
They don't always think
You have to read
beyond the lines,
and I am really bad at that.
And it created a lot of tension
in the company last year.
And we didn't build
any company culture.
We just let people roam free.
And it was very bad from
a management perspective.
People didn't feel they were
included into the company.
They felt outside of it.
They didn't feel included.
And so we are making
things better.
We are taking care of everyone.
We are doing meetings one
to one every other day,
and little perks and stuff, and
just talking a lot to people
so we don't have a bomb
coming from nowhere that you
didn't see, because it
can really harm you a lot.
ELISABETH BARGES: Sure.
And maybe it leads me to ask
you about, as you describe it,
some vulnerabilities
we can all have,
and maybe what can you
share with the audience,
maybe, Ludwine, about that
question-- about understanding
yourself, your weaknesses,
your vulnerabilities,
and try-- I don't know,
to use it or to ignore it.
I don't know, but how
do you deal with that?
LUDWINE PROBST: So I
started coding at 26,
and like Emily, I didn't
study computer science.
So I had a lot of complex.
I felt like impostor's
syndrome, as Camille told.
And for me, I find help
with women communities.
So I joined Duchess
France four years ago,
and it helps me a lot, because
I had a space, a safe space
to share my experience
with other women
and to learn from
those women, because I
wanted to talk at conferences
about technical stuff.
But because I was
really scared, I
decided to organize
an event with women.
So in this way, I had to
present and to give talk myself.
So it was very motivating
for me and challenging.
So for me, I think women
communities are very important,
and you have a lot of women
communities in Paris-- Women
Who Code, Ladies of Code,
Duchess France, and others.
So if I have an advice, maybe
join one of those communities.
Maybe it can help.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yes, we
know that dedicated events,
like for example dedicated
events for women,
women feel more comfortable to
come to these kind of events.
So I think it's really
important and useful
to have specific events,
because it seems that women are
more engaged and
willing to come,
even if we can wish to have not
this situation always, but just
a transition one.
Maybe I would like to conclude
with something more light--
lighter, and more about
your hobbies and yourself.
Can someone tell me about
what books you're reading?
Ludwine again?
LUDWINE PROBST: Yes.
For me, it's "Resonate"
from Nancy Duarte.
It's a book about how
to make a nice speech,
how to catch your
audience, because I
want to share my story,
my trip in conferences,
so I want to learn and
make a nice speech.
So this is my book.
ELISABETH BARGES: Someone else?
The microphone.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED:
For me, actually, I
have a graphic novel.
In fact, it's the bio
of Olympe de Gouges,
which is a great figure
of the French Revolution.
ELISABETH BARGES:
Very interesting.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: And,
well, she had a bad hand,
but she did a lot of amazing
things for women of this time.
And she stated the
rights of women.
ELISABETH BARGES:
Very interesting.
Thank you very much.
And maybe another personal
question, about the sites,
websites you like to visit,
I don't know, every day,
each morning.
Emily.
EMILY REESE: Yeah, sure.
ELISABETH BARGES: Don't
say Google, please.
EMILY REESE: Google.com.
The "New York Times"
is the best money
I spend every month for
a digital subscription.
I don't need the thing
in paper, but just
being able to go to that
every day keeps me away
from the kind of
clickbait headlines
that we're so used
to seeing, like
10 things that you must know
about this horrible crisis.
So I think it's good to
invest a little bit of money
every month in some good
journalism-- keep you grounded.
And then A List Apart, for
anyone who doesn't read it,
is for people who are
building things on the web.
It has a tendency to
go towards design.
But there are great articles
written all the time
on building websites
for everyone,
and not just for a
certain type of person.
Like you can imagine
the photo of someone
sitting out in the
grass with their laptop,
and they're smiling, and you
don't know how they have Wi-Fi,
but they're on the
website, and it's cool.
You imagine that as
your target user.
But A List Apart, a
lot of their content
focuses on making websites that
make people feel things and is
for someone who's
not your target user
normally, like someone who's
had a really bad day, someone
who just went through a really
difficult life experience,
and they end up on your
site, and you have a chance
to connect with them.
The way that you design your
page makes them feel something.
And if you can write technology
and write code and build
in that same way, where
you feel something
and the person on the
other side feels something,
I think that's what
creative technology is.
And I think that's the
direction we should go.
So I recommend reading both
the "New York Times" and A List
Apart.
ELISABETH BARGES: OK, thank you.
And what about
apps, mobile apps.
Melanie?
MELANIE CHRISTIN: Yeah, as
I said, I use Twitter a lot,
so It's kind of always
open on my phone.
Also, my most lifesaving
app must be Google Maps,
because I get lost all the time.
And so this really
changed my life.
To have a GPS in my pocket,
and I can go anywhere and not
get lost, this was
really a life changer.
And I use a lot also
an app called Day One.
It's a journaling app that
I enter every evening what
has been going on in my day.
And it keeps it synched
between all my devices.
And you can add photos.
So you can do researches,
like when was that,
at what time was this event?
I can't remember.
So you can search by tags,
or just some keywords.
So you can find your journal
entries from that day,
so you can remember
what happened
and have photos linked to it.
And it's all private.
So I like it to remember
everything that I've done,
to learn from it.
ELISABETH BARGES: Thank you.
And I have a personal question.
It's not-- you are not prepared,
but it's really simple.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: Oh my god.
ELISABETH BARGES:
But I'm sure you've
seen this kind of movement of
people waking up very, very
early, like 5 o'clock
in the morning,
to start with, I
don't know, meditation
and then running and then
breakfast and then reading
newspaper and then
starting to work.
Well, it looks
really amazing to me.
I'm not really prepared to that.
But I just would like to test,
to you as great entrepreneurs,
great tech leaders, what do you
what do you feel about this?
Are you practicing this?
Yes, you are.
EMILY REESE: A little bit.
I like waking up really
early, going for a run.
Being active is really
important when your job is
sitting in front of a computer.
That's the thing that I like
least about development,
is you're sitting there all day.
So wake up early,
have some coffee,
get started with your day.
I don't know, it's
really nice to just
have some time with yourself
before going on the internet.
MELANIE CHRISTIN: Yeah,
I walk to my work,
but that's not going to happen.
I mean, I'm not going
to wake up at 5:00.
This is not physically possible.
ELISABETH BARGES: Ludwine?
LUDWINE PROBST: No, I'm
more a 20 minutes person.
I mean, I just need 20
minutes, and then I go to work.
So yes, no.
ELISABETH BARGES: OK, and you?
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: Well, can we
negotiate 5:00 to go to 7:00?
So 7:00, it's just my breakfast
time, listening to news
and trying to
organize all my day.
So I just-- the time for
me, because I usually
end very late with meetings
and things like that.
So early morning is my time.
ELISABETH BARGES:
So not the majority,
but the movement is gaining in
France, so I'm really afraid.
SOPHIE ANNE BLED: I'm
doing yoga in the evening.
ELISABETH BARGES: Yeah, great.
I mean, yoga is great,
but not at 5:00.
That's my only--
SOPHIE ANNE BLED:
Not at 5:00, no.
ELISABETH BARGES: OK, thank
you very much to all of you.
A big round of applause, and
I hope it was interesting.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]